we love working on the World building
with Tim the sets the colors the palette
are you as obsessed with Wednesday Adams
as we are well we've got an intricate
breakdown of every location and design
aspect that made the show as bingeable
as it was and yes we're gonna be getting
handsy but more on that later I could do
this all day number one everyone's
favorite dismembered hand we were losing
it when we found out how thing was
really brought to life thing was
completely practical he was played by an
actor and magician named Victor Victor
was completely wrapped in a blue
bodysuit and the only visible part of
him was obviously his hand he was often
wheeled alongside Jenna Ortega on a
camera Dolly hiding the rest of his body
underneath tables behind corners and
many times behind Jenna herself and
don't worry we've got more on Jenna soon
we've praised her for her ability to
convey emotion without expression but
we've gotta give props to Victor for
conveying so much with just his hand
it's a really hard process because you
have to show emotion through a simple
hand that doesn't have a voice or
subtitles it's a lot of hard work to
show emotion through a hand I know a lot
of people won't understand but after
they see the season they will get it
number two did you notice how Wednesday
always stands out even when she's only
in black and white looks like a rainbow
vomited on your side that was a lot more
difficult to coordinate than you would
think take a look at the extras in the
background you'll never see them
sporting black and white please excuse
Wednesday she's alert you to color if
you take a look at Nevermore Academy and
compare it to the town of Jericho which
was built from the ground up by the
production team more on that later you
can see that color tactic popping up
again in Jericho everything is bright
and colorful you won't spot anything
colored black except of course Wednesday
Adams number three your typical New
England Town built specifically for the
show one of The Inspirations behind the
look of this town was Vermont which was
actually a lot more of a challenge to
capture than the crew had imagined also
fun fact did you know that the stores or
rather the facades of stores were based
on Charles Adam's original illustrations
there are so many little ways the show
pays homage to its predecessor the
production team also brought on
architecture and sculpting students from
Bucharest to bring the town to fruition
there was very little CGI used in the
creation of Jericho production designer
Mark Scruton had a field day setting up
this town being able to to design worlds
from scratch is what makes my job so
rewarding but being able to do it for
Tim Burton is a gift number four the
Gargoyles are more than an addition of
Gothic architecture did you notice that
the Gargoyles all show different
emotions they might also hold a clue to
the show's big mystery let us know in
the comments if you spotted it not only
that but the Gargoyles also represent
the different supernatural creatures
that attend the school even the archways
were designed to look like demonic faces
number five one of the most unique
aspects of the show is where it was
filmed you won't see a lot of media take
place in Romania all eight episodes of
the show were shot across 70 sets across
six sound stages and several locations
throughout Bucharest Romania one of the
major locations used for the Nevermore
exterior and aerial shots was kanta
kuzino Castle Mark scrutin envisioned a
New England Gothic mansion as the
setting for The Eccentric school special
effects were used to build on top of the
roof to give it more of that classic
Adams Family Vibe if you were to see
this castle in real life you'd realize
that it looks a lot more inviting and
way less spooky than it does on
Wednesday
it's a magical place
number six let's take a look inside
principal weem's office I did send a
photograph of myself in my office to my
agent and said is this what your office
looks like this amazing set is actually
a historic house and Monument built in
1874 that's utilized for principal
weem's office and the mezzanine right
outside it's located on Victory Avenue
right in the heart of downtown Bucharest
did you spot the bear in the very back
of her office that's an Easter egg we're
gonna get into a bit later I know the
suspense is killing you number seven
let's get more into Nevermore this
stunning Castle is another Historic
Landmark in Bucharest the style is
French neo-gothic and was designed and
built between 1911 and 1923. some of its
most telling features are the alluring
staircase the stained glass windows the
surrounding handrails columns and its
bright red brick exterior number eight a
lot was built from scratch at boopdale
Studios we're talking about the entire
town of Jericho Pilgrim world the
sheriff's house and the quad it makes
sense they would do so much there as its
eastern Europe's largest and longest
film studio that's been active in cinema
for over 60 years they do everything
from Construction Services to props
wardrobe and post-production number nine
also known as The Gates mansion this set
can be described as a very very old
house out in the countryside the
production team did an entire rework of
the house to make it Wednesday
appropriate we did extensive work to it
including building the double garage a
new entrance and driveway with the iron
gates and breaking down the whole
interior to give it the correct
abandoned house look number 10. there
are so many hidden references in the
series which ones were you able to pick
up on did you notice the back wall in
the Weathervane Cafe there are a bunch
of metal weather veins screwed to the
wall they were designed to reference Tim
Burton's other movies Tim was always our
first choice for the series Wednesday or
that the
air in principal Williams office is a
nod to the stuffed bear in The Adams
Family House in the original show from
the 1960s what about the music did you
notice the use of the harpsichord
throughout the show that's another nod
to the music from the original Adams
Family TV show number 11. wear the black
cats took their well-deserved victory
for the record I don't believe I'm
better than everyone else just that I'm
better than you this iconic competition
was filmed across two lakes in Romania
we're going to State the obvious
Wednesday is chock full of Edgar Allan
Poe references from this Lake
competition to the Raven dance the story
behind the PO cup not only the fact it
was filmed in the lakes that are called
some of Romania's Hidden Treasures but
that it's an actual tradition dating
back 125 years and named for nevermore's
most famous alumni we couldn't think of
a better setting for this competition to
take place
number 12. there are so many little
details in every costume did you notice
principal weem's costume was influenced
by Tippy Hedren's look as Melanie in
Alfred Hitchcock's the birds when it
came to the way everyone looked in
costume not one detail was too small
there's a lot to be said about every
costume piece but according to the
designer Colleen Atwood who is Tim
Burton's longtime collaborator her
approach was to Simply modernize The
Adams Family but still bring us that
hint of nostalgia with Wednesday we can
nail the iconic look right away with a
nod to the original pointed collar
little print dress and modernized
platform shoes and then put her in an
environment that she totally contrasts
with an American Happy Time public
school then you've given the nod to all
that's come before I wish you luck
we were definitely impressed with the
attention to detail and incredible lack
of CGI when it came to Wednesday what
did you think about the set design and
all the little details we definitely
missed our first time around give us
your thoughts in the comments